[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme à la gymnastique en fait oui
bonsoir à toutes et à tous quand même
assez mou bonsoir à toutes et à tous
ah super bon et bien merci pour votre
audace en tout cas pour ce soir donc
c'est bien tout cas dans ces
circonstances si difficiles donc comme
quoi vous êtes comme des passionnés
indiscutablement c'est un test
indiscutable alors
chers amis du prisme que vous soyez
fidèles abonnés ou spectateur régulier
ça fait vraiment du bien de se retrouver
bien sûr dans notre théâtre
après ces mois d'angoissé sanitaires et
bien entendu vous le savez est ce que je
vais vous dire demain peut bien entendu
s'inverser vous connaissez la situation
on va pas se le cacher donc à venir bien
sûr un certain
cela dit on va quand même me voir
quelque chose ce soir
début mars on le savait notre vie
culturelle s'est totalement arrêté brisé
dans son élan
comme d'ailleurs toute notre vie sociale
elle reprend progressivement mais n'a
toujours pas retrouvé son effervescence
son pétillant vous sachiez que l'on
travaille déjà en cours avec
l'agglomération sur les projets de
vaccins qui arrive normalement entre
décembre et juin et nous préparons même
déjà une opération sur les rangs pour
passer dans les conditions les plus
fiables bien sûr et les plus rapides
environ cent mille
personnes à vacciner donc donc dès qu'il
arrive dès qu'il est valide et déconner
l'autorisation du gouvernement bien sûr
je pense que vous aurez des nouvelles et
on se sera quand même sacrément rations
pour tout le monde et on débloquera je
pense à ce moment là vraiment les choses
le coc u19 lakovic 19 bien sûr a
lourdement impacté nos professionnels de
ce secteur
nos artistes et tous ceux autour d'eux
qui font le spectacle et je veux avoir
une pensée pour eux parce que je peux
vous dire c'est du jamais vu
c'est inédit dans l'histoire de notre
génération en tout cas donc cette soirée
c'est un signe d'espoir 1 une étape
majeure de la renaissance du prisme
aussi je suis très heureux bien sûr
d'accueillir de vous accueillir avec mon
adjoint à la culture laurent mazauric
vous connaissez tous bien et virgin et
marson notre célèbre directrice jeunes
ont fui par non plus ici je vois bien
pour vous présenter bien sûr cette
nouvelle saison culturelle ou prisme une
nouvelle fois vous êtes fidèle à ce
grand ce rendez vous rendez vous de
lancement de saison avec des aperçu de
la programmation à venir en forme de
clin d'oeil que nous a bien sûr préparé
virgin
bien sûr nous sommes moins nombreux que
d'habitude mais le contexte sanitaire de
cette rentrée culturelle nous y oblige
comme le disait un grand physicien of
kings il disait l'intelligence c'est la
capacité de s'adapter aux changements et
ont bien sûr on essaye d'être fidèle à
cela le premier spectacle est programmé
en janvier c'est un concert intimiste de
marc lavoine ce meutre est très fier
d'ailleurs il ya aussi beaucoup de
rendez vous familiaux du jeune public de
l'humour et nous en avons bien besoin
rires mais je vais évidemment laissé
l'équipe du prisme vous détailler le
contenu de cette nouvelle saison
elle s'inscrit dans la continuité des
précédentes que vous avez plébiscité
on ne change pas ce qui marche
théâtre de proximité le prisme est
l'atout principal de notre pôle culturel
municipal 17 mar il compte aussi le
signer cette la médiathèque et l'école
de musique alors bien soyez aussi une
activité assez forte aussi à la
commanderie où je pense que vous
connaissez donc voilà il ya quand même
une extension de cette vie culturelle et
c'est important
heil en cours et à 50 devenue municipale
en 2018 le prisme affichait une
fréquentation en hausse de 25% d'argent
profite pour féliciter les auteurs avant
d'être stoppée en plein succès par cette
fameuse crise sanitaire inédite et je
vous le rappel mondial mais cela n'a
rien enlevé à notre ambition culturelle
et au succès grandissant de cette salle
de spectacle la culture elle en cours
comme à saint-quentin c'est un art de
vivre qui réunit toutes les générations
elle est ouverte à tous généreuse
accessible elle nous ouvre l'esprit tout
en nous divertissant
car on peut être intelligent sans se
prendre au sérieux
chers amis comme une avant garde
éclairée vous avez un rôle fondamental à
jouer grâce au bouche à oreille très
important dans cette reprise d'activité
au prisme
dites à vos amis et votre famille ni le
plaisir que vous avez à venir ici les
émotions que cela vous procure partager
ce bonheur qui ravit nos yeux et nourrit
notre esprit
enfin pour conclure je tiens à remercier
celles et ceux qui ont contribué à faire
de cette programmation 2020 2021
une réussite culturelle laurent virginie
et toute son équipe est bien sûr je
voulais vous remercier vous cher public
d'être venu nombreux assister à cette
présentation
et bien entendu vous êtes conscient que
tout ce qu'on se dit ce soir bien
entendu on est obligé de tenir compte
des surprises que nous pouvons avoir
dans les jours qui viennent je souhaite
et je souhaite qu'elle soit bonne
je veux pas vous l'assurer mais donc
bien sûr tout cela bien sûr est relatif
à cela vous le savez très bien donc
votre présence démontre votre appétit de
la découverte votre attachement à la
culture et surtout et votre fidélité aux
prises et à toute son équipe
merci et bonne soirée à tous merci
beaucoup jean-michel pour ses mots après
cela je n'ai pas grand chose à rajouter
si ce n'est de vous dire de vous dire à
nouveau merci merci d'abord pour les
équipes du prisme parce que elle et nous
avons eu beaucoup de mal à vivre ce
confinement on peut le dire
virginie ça va pas être facile d'arrêter
cette activité qui nous passionne merci
d'être là parce que si vous n'êtes pas
là il n'y a pas de spectateur vient il
n'y a pas de troupes
il n'y a pas de chanteurs n'ya pas
d'acteurs ya pas de jongleurs n'y a pas
de circassiens ya plus rien ils vivent
grâce à nous et nous vivons grâce à eux
donc pour cela on a besoin de vous et je
tiens vraiment du fond du coeur à vous
remercier d'être là parce que sans
culture il n'y a pas de plaisir sans
plaisir il n'y a pas de vie et vaincre
et combattre la maladie c'est aussi
résisté et résisté c'est d'être présent
dans les salles de spectacle comme dans
les salles de cinéma en respectant les
esb arrière comme vous le faites ce soir
en emportant malheureusement des masques
mais je crois que le masque ne doit pas
nous empêcher de vivre notre passion
culturel donc en cela merci vous savez
que derrière la culture il y à beaucoup
de monde
il y à des entreprises et il a des
intermittents du spectacle ya des
techniciens il ya tous les métiers sont
présentés dans la culture
vous savez que on ne sait peut-être pas
assez souvent mais c'est avec le
tourisme deux premiers postes d'emploi
en france donc on peut parler de
secteurs économies majeures avec un
chiffre d'affaires qui avoisine et 7
milliards d'euros donc c'est très
important
vu beaucoup de monde l'exception
culturelle française est une réalité et
l'exception culturelle française
n'existe que par la qualité de ses
artistes
la qualité de ses productions la qualité
de l'ensemble de ces gens qui font le
spectacle
il n'existe que grâce à vous il existe
un peu grâce aux collectivités puisque
bien entendu les collectivités
territoriales financent à culture mais
comme le dirait notre mère les
collectivités territoriales ne sont pas
basés sur lourdes désolé de te
paraphraser elles vont chercher l'argent
dans notre poche dans la poche des
entreprises donc nous finançons la
culture pour exister il faut réfléchir
pour réfléchir il faut il prendre du
plaisir c'est votre présence faites le
savoir qui nous permettra de continuer à
faire ce métier que nous adorons en cela
soyez tous vraiment remercier sur ce je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée et
puis les discours les plus courts étant
les meilleurs je passe la parole à la
maîtresse de cérémonie de ce soir
virginie marson et je vous laisse
également entre les mains expertes de
ces artistes du grand show time bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous merci
[Applaudissements]
je crois oui oui ah ah super pour cela
concerne tout le monde
en fait on est les artistes du grand
show time bon alors vous ne voyez pas on
n'est pas sur scène parce qu'on est on
est en coulisse là on est juste à côté
on va faire notre entrée est en fait
nous on fait de l'impro donc on n'a pas
vraiment préparé notre entrée donc on va
avoir un peu besoin de vous pour le
début on a vous vous êtes vous êtes
contents d'être là déjà
ok ce cas quelqu'un qui n'est pas
content d'être là lèvent la main
ok d'accord bombe et cela maintenant du
coup on va on va vous demander de
choisir un début on a alors on a un
début classique qu'on maîtrise sur une
musique entraînante vous aller applaudir
des mains voilà on a une chorégraphe est
plutôt moyenne
mais en même temps ça met une bonne
ambiance franchement ça met une bonne
énergie pour démarrer ou sinon on vous
propose ce soir du 1 début théâtre
contemporain voilà va alors ça on n'a
pas travaillé mais on va sur un début
théâtre contemporain du coup on va se le
faire à l'applaudimètre
pour ceux qui veulent entrer classique
mais énergique et sympathique
applaudissent ya un an
ok ok pas mal pas mal
ok pour ceux qui veulent une entrée
théâtre contemporain un peu chelou mais
sympathique aussi tapé dépôt maintenant
taper des mains ok
franchement on a du mal à départager on
va tenter là on va se faire la première
non très classique donc si le début du
grand show time when musique numéro une
pour les régisseurs voilà on fait une
entrée vous nous accueillit spectacle
d'improvisation mesdames et messieurs je
vous demande d'accueillir nous mêmes les
improvisateurs du grand-chenal fait du
bruit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme
ok
m
aux parents pour que ça
quoi
avant son physique
m
bonsoir bonsoir donc c'est nous en fait
c'était moi j'étais derrière voilà on a
fait notre entrée plutôt cool hein ouais
ça vous a plu
j'ai vu personne danser c'est pour ça
est ce que quelqu'un de venir danser
avec nous non ok bon marester la joue on
va se présenter rapidement et je vous
présente julie voilà je lis ici vous
pouvez l'applaudir julie voilà et c'est
l'homme qui qui parlent souvent quand il
est caché c'est farid par le bien en
coulisses c'est vrai je suis enchanté
les oreilles de tous du coup nous on est
là pour lancer cette présentation de
saison
faire en sorte une une bonne ambiance
dans la salle que vous vous connaissiez
tous un peu à la fin et que vous ayez
envie de venir tous ensemble au théâtre
découvrir et bien cette saison
alors pour ça on a besoin de faire un
petit sondage d'abord pour mieux vous
connaître
je propose de donner un peu la lumière
mon message voilà comme ça en lumière
légère mais sans aveugler les gens et du
coup voilà nous c'est de l'impro c'est
interactif on discute avec vous vous
inquiétez pas personne ne va monter sur
scène
pas parce qu'on ne veut pas mais parce
que les mesures covin nous y oblige
sinon vous seriez tous montés sur scène
au moins une fois vous vous sentez
beaucoup mieux du coup là c'est très
simple je vous je vous pose une question
déjà je reste à voir qui a déjà assisté
à la présentation de saison à elancourt
lever la main s'il vous plaît a quand
même des habitués
alors qu'il n'a jamais assisté à une
présentation de saison elle encourt s'il
vous plaît lever la main très bien qui
n'a pas levé la main levé la main voilà
à moi tout le monde et j'ai monté mon d
aligner farid type socialistes
voteraient ballack août très bien on va
faire un peu connaissance pour démarrer
la soirée
je vous pose une question je compte
jusqu'à 3 vous répondez une question
simple je vous demander votre ville de
naissance
d'accord on a tous une ville de
naissance non mais voilà ce qui s'en
rappellent pas dit new york
ça nous ira très bien d'accord à trois
roues de balancer vraiment jeu à travers
pour masquer les filets quand même à la
sortie on vérifie
incollable sur les papiers attention à
troyes 1 2 3 ok alors évidemment nous on
entend beaucoup de choses
voilà monsieur vous venez d'où par
exemple c'est assez saint martin 2-2 dit
gel le dégel des deux pas de digère de
jijel sait où ça au malawi et puis m'a
dit que c'est par là en fait apparemment
c est juste là il ya des jeunes qui
naissent en eure-et-loir donc ces voix
là oui encore bien et vous habitez ou
non diagne moi je connais coignières
c'est vrai mais c'est sympa mais c'est
là-bas d'accord tu vois l'eure-et-loir
vous le monsieur avec aya avec le bec de
canard la barre oui vous êtes un canard
pour moi d'ici un canard à lunettes mais
un canard vous êtes né ou alors c'est le
monsieur de devant qui a parlé mais
c'est très bien voilà très bien saint
cyr l'école en même temps ils ont tous
les deux des lunettes
c'est vrai ou mai mais il y en a il a un
bec de canard comme hélas non oui ok
saint-cyr-l'ecole sait où saint cyr
l'école c'est maintenant ce soit on va
mettre les coudes et dire et là c'est la
banque est très bien ok juste vous
demander pour faire connaissance
regardez la personne qui est assis à
votre droite regardez la personne qu'à
cerveau droite si vous avez percée de
regarder la personne qui est au bout de
la bas à droite
voilà vraiment regarder quelqu'un en
tout cas regarder quelqu'un regardez
bien cette personne au jeu vous demander
en toute bienveillance et en toute
honnêteté évidemment de me donner une
note de 1 à 10 sur la physique de sur le
physique de cette personne voilà toute
bienveillance ça s'est pas créé oui je
dis en toute bienveillance et en toute
honnêteté alors ceux qui sont en couple
c'est le moment de dire la vérité 1
on y va on est en effet rang à 3 en
balance une note ceux qui veulent pas
dire dit new york ça nous va très bien
ok attention à 3 à 3
10 hockey on a souvent des dix ans quand
même moi on est des gens très beau on a
des gens là c'est le genre de coignières
tout de suite relève le niveau
et du coup à coignières que qu'est ce
que vous n'aimez pas faire parvint pas
forcément à quoi niamey dans la vie en
général qu'est ce que vous n'aimez pas
faire la vaisselle ou on est bien
d'accord
et vous monsieur c'est une certitude de
la vaisselle cela passe à jour votre
truc c'est pas du tout mais du coup vous
savez avec le grand show theme vous
allez tout aimé ouais ah bon j'ai même
ses costumes de doute fun et bien oui
mais si vous allez tout aimé avec le
grand chelem
par exemple la vaisselle on va vous
faire une mini impro un avant avant le
lancement de la présentation de saison
juste pour vous faire changer d'avis là
ce groupe-là anti vaisselle hockey amh
et on est aux jeux olympiques du lavage
de vaisselle d'accord d'accord vous avez
un des meilleurs concurrents d'accord et
maintenant on est lancé on se fait un
apéro pique donc qu'il a pas de
vaisselle
alors alors que le concurrent de
coignières s'approche de l'évier il est
prêt un show voilà des faits la
technique quan hyéroise
c'est à dire qu on s'échauffe les doigts
parce que la vaisselle à coignières ya
un sacré des beats alors que le voilà
ils comptent les assiettes avant a bien
entendu afin de rêver de savoir rhône la
saône à la regarder
il s'agit ni de son bronze bros couteau
brossac loire brossac où l'arbre aux
savoirs et trey parker que et voilà
alors une technique très simple à
coignières 1 c'est à dire qu'on
n'utilise pas de produits ménagers
bien entendu si sa salive autonettoyante
qui va suffire alors attention qui se
saisit de la première assiette le
regardez le il est incroyable attention
pour que ses partis alors attention le
premier assaut d irak irak l'irak les
raclures et que sa poignée revanche
beaucoup de gratens y jette j'étais
jeune et au regard des qualités
incroyables
il aura tout raflé dans l'est
non mais c'est incroyable pour le passé
ce matin dans 78 pouvoir va déménager
nettoyer josiah précédente et oui il
push mail qui fait tout lui-même qui
lave avec son propre sens regarder ça
heureusement que sa pilosité permet de
rater suffisamment le vend des assiettes
mais c'est impensable
wilson and nash et des boutons est ce
que tu manges renault s'est passé ton
juste je ne garantis pas mais en tout
cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le
concurrent au ballet verges oui j'avais
pas vu regarder les jette avec une
dextérité incroyable alors que oui la
chao aux ben voilà c'est une technique
absolument incroyable vous pouvez la
bleue dire à ce monsieur concurrents a
dit voyez la vaisselle en moins de 5
minutes et ça et ça dans le séduit c'est
une exclusivité
alors que nous regardons les nattes eux
il vient d'avoir et bien bon 9 pour le
degré de nettoyage bravo mieux il a eu 1
5 pour l'artistique
effectivement le frottage de thor
c'était un petit peu c'est trop merci
beaucoup on vous laisse maintenant aux
compagnies de virginie marsan qui n'a
toujours pas fille qui va vous faire
découvrir le reste de la saison a tout à
leur merci beaucoup
bonsoir c'est dur de reprendre dernière
parce que je vois sur une note un tout
petit peu moins décalés je donnais déjà
à vous dire à quel point on était
content moi même toute l'équipe du
prisme de pouvoir vous accueillir de
nouveau ici un lancement de saison c'est
toujours un moment un petit peu
particulier encore plus cette année ça
revêt une saveur toute particulière
venir au théâtre se rassembler partager
avec les artistes une même émotion
ces moments de rencontres passées
ensemble sont d'autant plus précieux que
nous en avons été privés pendant de
nombreux mois
alors attendre un retour à la normale
pour retrouver cet espace de vie
essentiel qu'est le spectacle vivant ou
plutôt choisir de s'adapter pour en
profiter dans les meilleures conditions
possibles alors pour cela on vous
demande d'ailleurs c'est le petit côté
hôtesse de l'air de bien conserver votre
masque pendant toute la durée de la
représentation et à la fin de la soirée
d'attendre les indications du personnel
de la salle pour bien quitter votre
place les uns après les autres
alors il ya une citation de sénèque moi
je ne citerai pas un scientifique mais
un dramaturge roumain à ses célèbres
cette situation parce qu'elles
traversent les siècles avec la même
pertinence quelle que soit l'époque mais
vous verrez que ça rejoint un peu ce que
monsieur fourgous nous disait la vie ce
n'est pas attendre que les orages passe
mais c'est apprendre à danser sous la
pluie et c'est le choix que nous faisons
avec vous dès ce soir en petit comité
pour commencer et puis on l'espère de
plus en plus nombreux si les conditions
le permettent
masques et distanciée mais réunis au
prisme avec le même envie s'émerveiller
rires contempler s'émouvoir partager on
vous promet une saison où la morosité
n'aura vraiment pas sa place mais je
vous propose tout de suite de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet c'est pour ça que
vous êtes venu et on va commencer par
parler musique avec un spectacle dont
monsieur fourgous vous a déjà un petit
peu parler puisqu'il s'agit de marc
lavoine qu'on accueillera pour ouvert et
ouvrir le bal au mois de janvier le 9
janvier c'est un invité de choix
on est très chanceux de l'avoir il
viendra dans une configuration très
intimiste uniquement accompagnée de son
pianiste alain antique et son compagnon
de longue date une invitation à la
découverte d'un monde empreint de poésie
dans lequel ses plus grandes chansons
côtoient celles d'artiste qui lui sont
chers de juliette gréco à catherine
ringer en passant par clara luciani une
ode à l'amour et aux artistes qu'il aime
on a tout de suite quelques notes à vous
faire écouter à écrire les chansons
doivent être dotées mots d'amour les
chansons candides un hôte a toujours été
pour
inspiré de la mer
quand tu pour changer derrière la nuque
la mer
changer je t'emmène est aussi offerte à
fringe aniche sur des appuis très au
restaurant qui met les petits plats dans
les grands
elle reposerait
machi où j'en étais
papa
tout va
mais tu auras pas
oui
alors c'est toujours un plaisir
d'accueillir tous les artistes au prisme
mais spécialement quand on a les invités
voilà un peu exceptionnel comme celui là
c'est vrai que notre salle elle permet
d'avoir une proximité avec la scène qui
est très agréable donc on espère vous
voir nombreux pour cette première sortie
de soirée de saison on continue en
musique avec une soirée aussi
exceptionnel même si très différentes
le 23 janvier un double plateau avec yum
trio et trans kabar on commence à 18h
avec guillaume clarinettiste virtuose et
son éternel odyssée du klezmer aux
musiques électroniques en passant par le
rock la musique contemporaine c'est
avant tout un besoin d'universalité
spiritualité qu'on le retrouve dans
chacun de ses albums et ses créations
c'est cette fois ci avec un trio enfin
dans un trio ou la compagne deux
musiciens tout aussi exceptionnel
frédéric deville au violoncelle et régis
huby au violon qui se lancent dans une
pièce alors inspiré évidemment de
l'authie de l'odyssée d'ulysse mais
aussi plus largement de la thématique de
l'exode
au delà de la performance physique et de
la virtuosité exceptionnelle du trio ce
spectacle se vit comme une exploration
un temps suspendue au delà du magic
et puis à 25 noeuds on bascule dans
autre chose avec une expérience
détonante et trans kabar une musique qui
brassent blues rock et saveurs maloya le
maloya c'est la musique traditionnelle
de la réunion le schéma musicale de mali
gaz et c'est le nom de leur dernier
album se résume à des morceaux
envoûtants avec un rythme qui se fait de
plus en plus dense au murano au fur et à
mesure que le le morceau progressent
pour mener à la transe et normalement si
tout va bien à l'irrésistible envie de
danser c'est envoûtant c'est diablement
efficace on est ravi de cette soirée on
a deux extraits à vous proposer
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oui
e
ouais
[Musique]
d'amigo dannielynn des rapides en
management ont gagné des baby quotas
dans ma vie
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
voilà on espère qu on vous verra
nombreux le 23 janvier pour danser dans
vos petites fauteuil mais danser quand
même alors on continue avec une artiste
qu'on aurait dû accueillir la saison
dernière au printemps et puis il nous a
fallu vraiment trouver un autre moment
pour vous la présenter cette saison tant
elle fait partie des plus belles
découvertes de cette génération musicale
c'est anne paceo mal à deux victoires du
jazz déjà à son actif six disques
seulement 35 ans elle fait de la
batterie depuis l'âge de 11 ans très
jeune avec des grands noms du jazz comme
christian escoudé elle a voyagé dans
plus de 45 pays pour sa carrière
puisqu'elle accompagné de nombreux
projets musicaux en dehors du sien et
elle ramène à chaque fois des sons qui
viennent enrichir son univers musical
constitué constellé d'influencé ethnique
véritable poème au monde
sur scène elle s'entoure d'un sextet et
depuis peu d'un chanteur ou d'une
chanteuse selon les espoirs et qui lui
permettent une grande liberté selon ses
morceaux ce que batteuse et chanteuse
s'est pas toujours forcément évident
donc là elle a trouvé je prends un très
bel équilibre pour que tous puissent se
déployer parfaitement et avec bright
shadows son dernier album elle nous
livre des compositions hybride entre pop
soul salle électrique jazz et même
quelques influences ouest africaine
quelques notes
[Musique]
randonnée
paris on souvent
tu ne sais plus
l'appartement
le coup
[Musique]
oui
non
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
voilà une passe et où et puis on
continue avec ben mazué qu'on
accueillera le samedi 13 mars
on a demandé un peu plus tôt qu'elle
était le coup de coeur de la saison
alors je sais pas si c'est un coup de
coeur moi j'aime tous les spectacles que
je vous présente mais celui-ci
accueillir banda ce but c'est vrai que
c'est un moment un peu spécial ça fait
un moment en fait que je suis cette
artiste peut-être dans certains d'entre
vous connaissent il ya une carrière qui
est exponentielle et puis voilà ça
n'avait jamais pu se faire donc là on
est ravi d'avoir trouvé le bon endroit
pour qu'on puisse l'accueillir aux
prises sur scène d'annemasse b c'est à
la fois la garantie une grande émotion
grâce à des textes sublimes une langue
maîtrisée et en même temps beaucoup
d'humour et de légèreté
ce poète contemporain qui s'inscrit un
peu dans la lignée des artistes comme
grand corps malade construit ses albums
quand on construit un roman il raconte
une histoire et il nous promet avec la
sortie de ce nouvel album qui s'intitule
paradis alors je sais pas si elle part
asie mais en tout cas une soirée hors du
temps loin de nos préoccupations
quotidiennes
une soirée comme une ode au voyage à la
recherche du soi un extrait
[Musique]
j'arrête de penser qu'on vient de stock
ja de précieuses couilles je me suis
jamais trop bien
à côté de ça il ya le silence de mes
amis à qui j'ai renoncé car amour et qui
me rappelle qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est que
ni elle ni le temps pour ne serait-ce
que les reconquérir
et puis et puis on vieillit on comprend
le gens qui nous entourent
plus on vieillit on comprend tout court
alors il ya l'amour des enfants avec ça
tu manques plus de rien moi je les aime
tellement justement j'ai tout le temps
peur de pas faire bien vous dire qu'on
parle des blessures faites par le regard
d'un père la moitié des gens malheureux
sur cette terre leçons de cette manière
à quoi sert vraiment l'exigence pourront
soit être excellent quand on voit dans
quel déshérence se retrouve le génie
souvent
[Musique]
apprendre à être ce que je m'emploie ce
que je veux c'est bien plus important
que ce que je suis et garonne s'est fait
ce que j'ai fait en fait ce que je veux
encore moins faites ce que je dis est ce
qu'elle a tant mieux pour la musique et
pour l'énergie à temps mais pour les
enfants
[Musique]
ping
jeanne ou penser
[Musique]
j'arrête de près
alors les premières dates de cette
tournée sont complètes à paris donc on
est d'autant plus content que vous ayez
l'opportunité de venir ici à l emploi
aux prises pour le découvrir
on continue toujours en musique avec une
petite pépite qu'on a découvert en
concert à l'automne dernier registre
très différent thomas chou-fleur junior
un ovni sur la planète du blues au rock
il fait ses compositions une prouesse
technique qui à chaque live mérite un
respect est indéniable un one man band
dont on ne sait plus si c'est lui qui
possède ces instruments ou l' inverse du
blues mais aussi de la country et du
rock pour cet inclassable qui a été le
coup de coeur de nombreux festivals de
jazz à vienne blues sur seine est donc
au prisme cette saison
cette baisse touche une corde
je ne sais pas
de chapet
m
[Musique]
voilà ça avec thomas qu'on clôt le
chapitre de la musique sur cette saison
on va maintenant parler de théâtre et de
danse
il y en aura beaucoup pendant la panda
toute cette saison entre janvier et juin
on commence par un spectacle qui
s'appelle le champ des possibles qu'on
présentera le mardi 2 février
ce seul en scène est la troisième d'une
trés le troisième d'une trilogie initiée
par élise noirot avec d'abord la banane
américaine puis pour que tu m'aimes
encore les deux premiers spectacles de
la trilogie
on y suit élise au fil des âges enfant
puis adolescente et enfin jeunes adultes
c'est à ce moment qu'on la retrouve dans
le champ des possibles à 20 ans
justement quand tout est possible encore
et que les voix de l'émancipation sont
toutes ouvertes le moment de ses
premiers choix d'adulte parfois décisif
parfois aussi contre la vie parentale
c'est tout cela qui élisent nous raconte
avec beaucoup de sensibilité d'humour de
délicatesse elle est programmée au
théâtre du rond point à paris
tout l'automne et nous aurons le plaisir
de l'accueillir ici une artiste totale
qu'il faut vraiment découvrir sur scène
[Musique]
le temps
stéphane
[Musique]
m
tous ceux qui souhaiteront a dit il
[Musique]
et
oh
à
c
alors église marot ça fait partie des
artistes que je suis aussi depuis
longtemps on l'a accueilli d'ailleurs il
ya une dizaine d'années à la ferme du
mousseau elle était toute jeune
aucun de ces spectacles n'existait
encore alors qu' on l'a accompagné voilà
dans ses premiers pas dans sa vie
professionnelle en tant qu'artiste et
puis voilà c'est l'un des coups de coeur
du festival d'avignon alors pas de cette
année mais l'année précédente
voilà je suis ravie je suis ravi déjà de
son succès et puis je suis ravi qu'on
puisse l'accueillir cette année on
continue avec un autre seul en scène un
irish story alors dans une toute autre
couleur mais avec une énergie identique
la comédienne kelly rivière joue le
personnage de kelly ruisseau et aborde
la question d'un mémoire individuelle et
familiale dans un spectacle drôle et
fantasque l inventivité débordante
la jeune femme se penche sur la
disparition mystérieuse de son grand
père peter o farrel venu à londres dans
les années 50 comme tant d'autres pour
reconstruire la capitale après guerre et
puis les disparaît dans les années 70
de ce point de départ se font et se
défont des personnages aux silhouettes
mordante au défaut cocasses et aux
mimiques savamment étudié en cherchant
avec obstination cet éternel absent
qu'elle y fait revivre avec humour et
émotion toute une famille marquée par
l'exil la comédienne nous offre ici une
histoire si intime qu'elle en devient
universel donc un spectacle qui voit là
également un seul en scène dans une
autre énergie on est vraiment dans
l'esprit de l' enquête qui va se
dérouler on la suit voilà allez
rencontrer les membres de sa famille et
puis en rencontrant les membres de sa
famille voilà on parle de choses parfois
qui fâche qui ressurgissent sans qu'on
puisse y attend c'est vraiment une
exploration voilà assez intime et puis
aussi universel puisque voilà les
secrets de famille on en a tous un petit
peu parfois
et elle réussit voilà à tourner ça avec
beaucoup de vrai beaucoup de délicatesse
je suis ravi et également de proposer ce
spectacle est maintenant pour vous
parler de la suite je vais demander à
mathieu l'étuvé metteur en scène du cac
liban théâtre que nous aurons en
résidence cette année avec deux
propositions théâtrales de me rejoindre
puisqu'il est là ce soir pour pouvoir
parler un peu plus de son travail et de
cet accueil bonsoir mathieu
merci d'être là tu peux le croire que tu
peux le laisser sur la table et c'est
ces essais prévus points bonsoir
alors on est ravis on accueille le cas
liban théâtre pour la première fois au
prisme cette saison avec deux spectacles
red bull en première partie et puis une
création
peut-être on peut regarder tout de suite
un petit extrait de reading bull et puis
après on en parlera un peu plus en
détail avec toi et je suis je suis avec
la moutarde champion du monde des poids
moyens le tour du monde
le torchis arrive entré chez lui chaque
soir vers minuit avec quelques centaines
de dollars en poche devant le savait
premier gros coup je transpirais juste
énervé
quand harry est passé devant moi
je lui emboîter le pas
s'il faut filer derrière mais en
sciences pas vu non
et je lui à coups de tuyaux sur le crâne
je sens le terrain vague
il s'est courbé gémissant sa maman
alors j'ai perdu les pédales sous les
yeux mais c'est quoi nier
[Musique]
alors sur l'ensemble des spectacles de
la compagnie il ya un fil rouge très
présent c'est le cinéma est ce que tu
peux nous dire pourquoi et comment ton
travail entre en résonance avec le
septième art bah justement il faut venir
voir en attendant biblique qui sera
jouée je sais plus la date le à 16 mars
le 16 mars voilà dans lequel ge explique
un peu tout ça de manière un peu
particulière très personnel
d'où ça vient voilà de mon histoire
c'est à dire que moi j'ai j'ai commencé
le théâtre un peu par la petite porte et
puis je me suis construit une identité
au niveau de la scène avec avec ma
culture et qui est très marquée par le
cinéma
et donc voilà c'est une une écriture qui
qui alors on le voit dans le rating bull
mais qui mélangent comme ça le théâtre
récit la danse hip hop l'image animée
la musique en attendant mobilisent c'est
autre chose de le spectacle suivant je
sais pas si je dois en parler expliqué
après d'abord parlé de reading boulbon
qui sont des images qu'on vient de voir
un rating bull c'est un film culte pour
beaucoup c'est un des premiers gros
succès je crois du duo scorsese de niro
et raconte l'histoire vraie de jake la
motta champion du monde de boxe dont la
vie est marquée par une rage continue
c'est très frappant à la fois dans le
film est dans la pièce et qu'est ce qui
t'a motivé du coup pour spécialement ce
film cette histoire là c'est pas du tout
film de scorsese parce que j'adore qui
est magnifique mais si je mens a été
tenue à ça je n'aurais jamais rien fait
non c'est justement en découvrant
l'histoire originelle l'autobiographie
de cech la motta le boxeur qui a écrit
ça avec deux journalistes et et en
découvrant son histoire en fait j'ai
trouvé ce récit assez bouleversant et il
ya une dimension dans dans l'histoire
d'origine qui n'apparaît pas du tout
dans le film de scorsese et qui
sous-tend en fait toute son histoire et
toute sa carrière et donc je vais pas
révéler parce que c'est un peu le
comment dire le le point le plus
important de tous dans dans le spectacle
est un revirement comme ça il ya une
espèce de basculement et voilà qui est
très dramatique et
avec une dimension un peu
shakespearienne donc moi c'est ce qui
m'a intéressé dans ce récit la petite
histoire aussi c'est que j'ai fait un
peu de boxe il ya longtemps et puis
voilà j'avais aussi ce cette passion à
la fois pour le film de scorsese mais
aussi pour pour cette discipline
d'accord esthétiquement reading où il
mélange de différentes disciplines on a
vu dans l'extrait du théâtre de la
musique en live de la danse hip hop une
création vidéo singulière pour arriver à
une proposition très forte visuellement
c'est ce qui est marquant quand on voit
le spectacle est ce que tu peux nous en
dire plus du coup sûr cette dimension-là
très esthétique c'est encore une fois
c'est une écriture qui est venu qui
c'est qui sait composer avec cette
équipe qui est avec laquelle je
travaille depuis qui est assez
fantastique donc antoine aubin qui fait
les animations vidéo
le musicien olivier en entier qui est
présent au plateau qui fait de la
musique électro et puis frédéric fall a
donc un super danseurs qui travaille
avec la compagnie hors série basée à
bordeaux et en fait on a vraiment créé
cette forme tous ensemble et c'est
vraiment à travers ce spectacle que j'ai
voilà j'ai trouvé mon mon style en
quelque sorte donc ça s'est fait
vraiment de manière un peu un peu
collective quoi c'est très particulier
et enfin venez voir mais en règle
générale c'est un spectacle qui marche
très très bien et c'est un spectacle
coup de poing sans vous verrez affaire
devient jeu de mourir un peu de ça c'est
noir ça très différents le récit en
lieux met assez formés mais ça n'a
vraiment ça n'a rien à voir avec le film
c'est bien de voir les deux parce que
ces deux choses complètement différentes
et alors le deuxième spectacle est une
création qui sera réalisé en partie au
prisme
en attendant billy alors il ya une
multiples rebondissements puisque
c'était pas ce spectacle qu'on devait
accueillir à l'origine est-ce que du
coup tu peux nous dire à quoi on peut
s'attendre sur ce projet qui devait être
à l'origine
friedkin connection ouais alors moi je
raconte un peu l'anecdote parce que ce
spectacle il est très particulier
je peux pas tellement vous dire ce que
vous allez voir parce que voilà moi même
si on l'a c'est vraiment le champ de la
chanteuse de l'inconnu et du c'est très
très particulier mais la petite histoire
c'est qu'en fait je devais adapter les
mémoires du cinéaste william friedkin
alors je sais pas si les gens
identifient
c'est le cinéaste qui a fait l'exorciste
french connection notamment et donc
j'étais j'avais lu ses mémoires est
pareil j'avais eu un coup de coeur pour
ce texte est pour ce personnage qui
était un peu hors norme et une vie
encore une fois assez particulière et
donc quand on a échangé avec lui depuis
2000 2010 est ont été en lien direct et
en août je lui envoie la dernière
version de l'adaptation et là il me
répond de manière très laconique je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ton concept je ne
te donne pas les droits
alors qu'ils étaient informés de la
direction voilà moi j'avais souhaité le
rencontrer
donc c'était un petit peu dur quand même
et donc voilà
coup de massue que faire quand on doit
créer avec des partenaires notamment
avec le centre dramatique national de
rouen chez qui on va créer donc je me
suis dit hé bien tant pis friedkin ne
veux pas moi j'ai envie de parler du
cinéma justement mon amour pour le
cinéma et donc je vais essayer d'écrire
là-dessus donc le spectacle part de
cette situation et parle pour le coup
des affres de la création non pas d'un
cinéaste mais d'un metteur en scène en
l'occurrence fin c'est une espèce de
garce à ce que le personnage que je me
suis créé un peu la woody allen mais
voilà qui va parler de toutes les
difficultés auxquelles on est encore on
est confronté en tant que metteur en
scène de théâtre
mais voilà ça reste un hommage au cinéma
on traverse un peu des films comme ça et
puis une dimension très personnelle
puisque ça va ça parle de moi aussi
merci mathieu merci pour six mois en
tout cas si vous aimez le théâtre le
cinéma si vous avez envie d'être surpris
red bull le 9 février en attendant billy
le mardi 16 mars lorsqu'il bonne soirée
en vain
on va parler de deux danses un petit peu
maintenant la danse qui fait partie de
l'adn du prisme qui est partie des d
esthétique qu'on a beaucoup accompagné
on continue toujours
on accompagne un spectacle qui s'appelle
dimanche éperdument de la compagnie mémé
banjo chorégraphe lionel hoche c'est une
création qui se fera en grande partie au
prisme en partenariat avec la mission
danse de saint quentin en yvelines
la compagnie collabore depuis la saison
dernière avec nos élèves de l'école
municipale de danse ça fait partie aussi
des choses qu'on privilégie c'est-à-dire
d'accueillir des artistes professionnels
qu'ils puissent transmettre
voilà leur savoir leur savoir-faire à
nous élève à nos jeunes amateurs donc y
aura aussi un spectacle qui sera proposé
dans un second temps et puis une
création professionnelle dimanche
éperdument lionel hoche ne pouvait pas
être présent ce soir mais vous a préparé
un petit message
bonsoir je suis lyonnais loches
chorégraphe ma compagnie est en
résidence à la mission danse de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis déjà une
saison nous avons pas mal oeuvré sur
terrain avec la diffusion du répertoire
des créations des répétitions des
performances et pas mal d'action
sensibilisation en tout genre nous avons
plusieurs partenaires ici dont le prisme
pour cette nouvelle création de dimanche
éperdument qui aura lieu le 15 janvier
prochain
cette pièce qui est une pièce
chorégraphique à proprement parler est
aussi une forme de récital avec
l'occasion d'entendre en live eu pas mal
de standards de jazz que vous connaissez
certainement
c'est une pièce qui est sûr l'espoir en
fait une pièce qui veut
réanimé on va dire toute la poésie du
monde on part d'un endroit assez noir
d'une espèce de grottes métaphysique
d'un trou noir d'un monde calciné fini
et puis on construit petit à petit de
quoi faire basculer tout ça vers un
final très très flamboyant août où tous
les espoirs sont permis tous les rêves
de l'homme et de l'humanité sont réunis
dans une espèce de folklore un peu
invraisemblable
et tout ça pour pour nous assurer de
retrouver à chaque fois la possibilité
de rebondir de retrouver la langue
l'élan et de participer à une
reconstruction en tout cas en tout cas
là au rêve d'un monde meilleur et en
commençant pas rêver on arrivera
certainement aboutir quelque part voilà
j'espère vous retrouver tous à ce
moment-là du 15 janvier prochain
j'espère que je me trompe pas de date et
partager ce moment particulier poétique
et ont joué avec vous au revoir
alors on revient sur du théâtre
maintenant avec un monument
de la littérature si un autre bergerac
vendredi 7 mai le chef-d'oeuvre d'edmond
rostand porté par une compagnie de
jeunes comédiens brillant et inventif
les échappés de la coulisse sont tous
connus au conservatoire est à l'image de
cette pièce il se joue des codes
préétabli du théâtre la poésie du texte
est préservée tout en étant rendu plus
actuel de la même manière ils ont
préparé un petit message pour vous il en
parle bien mieux que moi bonsoir à
toutes et bonsoir à tous on est vraiment
désolé de ne pas pouvoir être avec vous
ce soir malheureusement on travaille sur
un autre spectacle on n'a pas pu faire
le déplacement mais on est très heureux
d'être au prisme le 7 mai pour présenter
notre cyrano de bergerac de la compagnie
des échappés de la coulisse l'idée
c'était pas de monter une énième version
de cyrano c'était plus de pour nous voir
comment est ce que ce texte pouvait nous
touchent et déjà aujourd'hui toucher les
gens d'aujourd'hui comment est-ce que
l'alexandrin pouvait toucher les gens
d'aujourd'hui comment est ce que ça
pourrait être un mode de langage
actuel comment est ce qu'on fait de
cette pièce qui est un classique
comment est ce qu'on la réinvente aussi
comment est ce qu'on va chercher
l'histoire dans l'histoire qu'on n'avait
peut-être pas vu comment est ce qu'on
s'amuse avec tout ça avec cette épopée
fantastique avec plein de personnages
l'idée c'était aussi d'emmener le
spectateur en immersion un peu dans pour
vivre le spectacle vraiment de
l'intérieur et donc de pouvoir se
balader même parfois dans les décors de
pouvoir évoluer dans la pièce et pas
juste être spectateur de la pièce nous
on aime beaucoup faire dire ce mot
spectateurs respecte acteurs et
spectateurs de participer avec nous à
cette grande à cette grande épopée à
cette grande histoire dont il ya de la
joute verbale
il ya de la guerre il ya de l'amour on
va passer une soirée formidable on
espère vous voir le plus nombreux
nombreuses possibles le 7 mai aux prises
avec nous bonne soirée
alors on continue avec un ovni cette
fois ci la convivialité mardi 23 mars ce
spectacle sous titré la faute
d'orthographe
la convivialité est une conférence pop
et iconoclaste à leur pop comme
populaire car l'érudition et expliquer
et partager nos imposé et iconoclaste
sinon irrévérencieuse parce qu'on
s'autorise ici et c'est même le sujet
central de cette soirée à discuter la
règle en l'occurrence celles nombreuses
de l'orthographe accord du participe
passé autre bizarrerie en tout genre on
vous invite à un voyage dans les
déguisements de votre esprit critique
mais ils en parlent également on a un
petit extrait à vous proposer
[Musique]
employé avec l'auxiliaire avoir le
participe passé s'accordent en genre et
en nombre avec le complément d'objet
direct quand celui ci le précède
les crêpes que j'ai mangé es par contre
quand le complément d'objet suit le
participent
il reste invariable j'ai mangé et les
crêpes alors pourquoi pourquoi avant
mais pas après
toujours moyen âge les mêmes moi non des
conditions de travail difficiles
travaillent dans des monastères mal
chauffés mal éclairé avec des plumes
d'animaux sous la dictée quand le moine
écrit par exemple les pieds que jésus à
laver mais un simple regard vers la
gauche permet d'identifier ce que jésus
à laver il avait quoi les pieds donc le
moinde accorde un problème par contre
quand le moins décrivait jésus à laver
mais il se dit jésus elle avec quoi je
sais pas fait attendre
ça va probablement revenir dans la suite
du texte avant la fête de pâques
sachant que son heure était venue
le diable avait déjà inspiré au coeur
judas iscariot risque simon le dessein
de le livrer sur les bords du lac de
tibériade et patati et patata
les pieds
à
oh
à tous les coups quand le moine est
arrivé à les pieds il a oublié qu'il
avait un participant
était de l'observation de cet oubli donc
de cette erreur particulièrement
fréquentes dans les manuscrits du moyen
âge qu'on a tiré la règle voilà pourquoi
avant mais pas après alors à l'école les
enfants se demande pourquoi pourquoi un
x pourquoi avant et pas après pourquoi
pas de t et quand les enfants demandent
pourquoi on leur explique comment
comment on écrit comment on accorde
pourquoi est ce que l'esprit critique
s'arrête au seuil de l'orthographe c'est
parce qu'on a tous appris à ne plus se
demander pourquoi alors c'est un
spectacle est passionnant on riait on
apprend plein de choses c'est un duo de
professeur de linguistique belge ça fait
des années qu'ils tournent ce spectacle
ils ont fait des conférences tedx voilà
on
on participe avec eux à restaurer cet
espace de convivialité que la langue
française ne devrait jamais quitter
et puis on voit là on prend du recul
aussi sur quelque chose qu'on manipule
tous les jours c'est à dire voilà notre
langue maternelle langue française et
donc ses voiles assez jubilatoire je
vous le conseille vivement
on revient sur du théâtre avec le cercle
et des illusionnistes la pièce aux
multiples molière d' alexis michalik
metteur en scène prodige de ces
dernières années spécialiste des récit à
tiroirs aux multiples personnages qui
racontent souvent la petite histoire
dans la grande
ici il nous entraîne sur la naissance du
quine et au graff toujours un peu dans
le cinéma il nous entraîne dans une
épopée virevoltante le rythme est vif
les numéros de magie facétieux parce que
oui à de la magie et la fantaisie est
l'invention de tous les instants alexis
michalik profit si encore une fois son
grand talent pour cette mise en scène
centré sur l'art de l'illusion et
surtout les arts de la scène et de la
création
écoute cette histoire
avril oui c'est moi excusez-moi
l'automate là derrière l'armoire c'est
l'original qu'est ce que c'est
ni pro votre machine pour total un
nombre de ses dunks et un concept
pirelli days mélanie manager en jeu et
si vous vous y donnant une
représentation
comment il peut connaître en mairie
samir au mécanisme horloger et apprentis
escamoteurs le public a l'air d'aimer
tu regardes robert houdin 1805 1871 et
après le théâtre a fermé mais les bus
350 mille francs au méliès
[Musique]
quoi
pour en inventer un nouveau langage
lui-même avait acquitté de rapport
la musique la magie quand j'étais môme
mon truc c'était plutôt la magie on
avait accueilli aux prises mais il ya
quelques années le premier succès d'
alexis michalik le porteur d'histoire
pour ceux qui lui ont peut-être
découvert à l'époque ici on est vraiment
dans la même lignée avec des allers
retours entre le passé et présent sur et
on mène une enquête comme ça qui nous
emmène à un dénouement complètement
surprenant voilà donc on est ravis
d'accueillir alexis avec ce spectacle
qui prouve encore une fois son grand
talent on va passer maintenant un
troisième chapitre on va parler d'humour
et de comédie avec pour commencer à
bérengère krief mardi 19 janvier
son nouveau spectacle s'intitule amour
marque une véritable renaissance
scénique pour la première fois elle
délaisse l'image girly qui lui collera
qui lui collait à la peau pour se
révéler telle qu'elle est piquante plein
d'autodérision dans une mise en scène
quasi féerique
elle questionne avec justesse et
sincérité sa relation au sentiment
amoureux à la féminité depuis son
adolescence le tout sur fond de nicole
croisille ou dalida du personnage au
contenu c'est vraiment merveilleux c'est
très beau elle se libère des codes
traditionnels du one man show
préparez-vous vraiment un tourbillon de
costumes de chorégraphies de chansons et
même quelques acrobaties une comédie
maintenant dix ans après le samedi févry
6 février
une comédie grinçante avec une
distribution de choix bruno solo mélanie
page julien boisselier dans une mise en
scène de nicolas briançon pour une pièce
écrite par david foenkinos
autant vous dire que à tous les niveaux
c'est très bien joué très bien écrit
bien mise en scène j'ai vu beaucoup de
comédies l'an dernier pour pouvoir vous
ramener ce que moi j'estime en tout cas
être l'eau le haut du panier
il en parle très bien d'une petite
interview qu'ils ont réalisés dit
quelque chose
temps présent
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça dépend de la femme saleh pour du
copain surtout une question charisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
question de macho oui c'est vrai qu'est
ce que c'est que cette question de macho
[Musique]
tout est une question charisme c'est
toujours pareil mais en fait il a il ya
beaucoup de questions mais il a une
réponse est oui
oh
je préfère jacqueline et michel c'est
les soirs il faut faire garder les
enfants
[Musique]
dans le vie d'un couple est souvent
calqué sur la durée d'un caddie fait
romantique
quoi qu'on fasse
ce trio en forme toujours un cocu et à
chaque fois ce caucus c'est toi on
revient sur un seul en scène avec
mathieu madénian le 6 mars présenté au
rond point l'an dernier ce spectacle a
cartonné il est joué à guichet fermé et
c'est un spectacle c'est le nom du
spectacle un spectacle familial celui
qui a fait ses armes chez michel drucker
puis à charlie hebdo que vous pouvez
voir aussi dans des séries sur sur tf1
notamment
il a cette fois décidé de nous parler de
famille avec tout ce que cela implique
de vexations mal digéré de dîner un peu
alcoolisés qui finissent mal
et puis de jalousie fraternelle alors
plutôt que de se payer un spsi bas ses
névroses
mathieu madénian il essaie de les guérir
avec vous dans le cadre d'une hilarante
introspection encore une fois ici c'est
très bien écrit c'est sincère et c'est
absolument à découvrir quel comédien a
vraiment trouvé le juste endroit
déquilibre pour faire rire puis aussi
pour émouvoir
on revient maintenant avec de la comédie
la vie trépidante de brigitte tornade
samedi 10 avril c'est le molière de la
comédie 2020 alors brigitte tornade à
l'origine c'est une série radiophonique
qui a été créé pour france culture dans
le cadre de l'émission la vie moderne
et puis elle était prévue pour une
saison passée a tellement bien marché
qu'ils ont fait 10 brigitte tornade à la
survie les auditeurs qui se sont
reconnus dans le joyeux quotidien de
cette famille à mille à l'heure sous
l'impulsion d'eléonore gens qui est
qu'ils jouent brigitte dans la pièce une
adaptation au théâtre par l'auteure
elle-même camille colère s'est imposé
comme une évidence
une façon de donner un petit peu plus
corps à cette vie trépidante n'a un
petit extrait c'est quoi le problème
[Musique]
adam levine qui fait quatre gosses qui
dit qu'elle me privilégier sa vie
professionnelle s'est pas créé non plus
à rien je m'aime plus de former regarde
mes cinq étaient des non pas obligé de
répondre
[Applaudissements]
bon visite dans les couches illégaux
cela parce que ça fait déjà si je
voulais trouver bol faudrait que je
m'organise avec la baby-sitter haut mais
ya pas mort d'homme non plus c'était
fringues sas ramasse
franchement tu frise le burn out
maternel en ce moment le burn out nas et
on peut même pas faire de burnout soit
maternelle quand on est mère de famille
voilées mais même dans le burn out ou
encore patiné thématiques les faut que
tu dis pas non parce que c'est une
blague tu me dépanne avec des gorges va
directement à pékin on se dépêche est de
voir les cours se bougeant la charge
mentale juste à fois je reviendrai
moi c'est terminé alors pour la petite
histoire en plus vincent jonquet et
eleanor jonquière et de comédiens qu'ils
sont mari et femme dans la pièce se sont
aussi dans la vie et ils ont aussi trois
enfants les trois enfants qui sont tous
les soirs avec eux sur ce ne sont pas
les leurs mais c'est une vraie prouesse
d'avoir des enfants comédiens et puis là
pour le coup c'est extrêmement bien dosé
le décor est hyper réaliste on s'y
croirait on se croirait que voilà tous
les matins en train de speed et pour
emmener les enfants à l'école pour qui
va les chercher ce soir pensez vraiment
très très bien pensée très bien trouvé
on continue avec un seul en scène marina
rollmann vendredi 21 mai alors vous
connaissez peut-être marina à l'effet
des chroniques sur france inter c'est
une jeune humoriste suisse elle puise
son inspiration dans le stand up
américain
son spectacle également se jouent à
guichet fermé plus espiègle que trash
elle pose un regard aiguisé sur notre
quotidien et les absurdités qui le
traversent
on est là pour sauver la planète ce soir
mais paraît qu'il faudrait qu'on prenne
soin de nos aussi qu'on se sauve nous il
faut qu'on fasse du sport vous savez ça
montre tout le monde va faire du sport
tout le monde autour de moi faire du
sport j'en peux plus
chaque fois que tu allumes un réseau
social il ya des copains qui met des
photos de tout transpirant avec des
slogans non pineau game
moi je nos pays juste arrête tu veux
courir 20 par devant et arrêtons de nous
fréquenter
voilà non il ya des gens qui font du
sport c'est bien il ya un sport qui me
laisse un peu sceptique en ce moment qui
est très à la mode c'est le crossfit
est-ce que voyez ce que c'est le
crossfit montreux mais ce que c'est
d'être aussi alors que les gens ne
voient pas le crossfit une excuse
d'aérobic de l'extrême qui à la mode
depuis quelques années où les gens se
prépare la guerre
clairement c'est à dire si un jour les
allemands reviennent c'est les mecs qui
sautent dans des pneus avec des
ceintures lester qui vont s'en sortir
assez sûr très très bien le crossfit le
crossfit c'est vraiment j'en vois la
serna et robic mais vraiment poussé où
il ya des mecs en lycra qui tu crées
dessus pendant deux heures et toi tu
portes des poids dessus plus gros tu
t'appelles les seuls où il faut du cran
si tu reconnais assez vite parce que
c'est les seules salles où il ya des
connards mi-janvier qui courent à
l'extérieur en short avec des pois à la
main on dirait qu'ils essaient de
braquer en fitness c'est pathétique
non lui qu'il use groupe s'appelle et où
le produit ce que je comprends pas dans
le crossfit c'est que je comprends
vraiment l'idée qu'on fasse du sport à
part ça plus sérieusement je comprends
les dépenses entretiennent qu'on aille
faire un jogging mais le crossfit c'est
vraiment un truc où tu pousses ton corps
à des extrêmes genre régulièrement des
cures de crossfit ya des gens qui
vomissent tu as envie de prendre un
abonnement pour vomir toi qu'est-ce que
et puis vendredi 19 mars le grand show
time alors vous en avez déjà vu un petit
bout tout à l'heure c'est un des rendez
vous culte du point virgule
vous connaissez certains des
protagonistes puisque julie chaise que
vous avez vu elle assure pour le prisme
la direction artistique des plateaux du
7-8 humour trois fois par an cette fois
on accueillera l'équipe au complet pour
une soirée placée sous le signe de
l'impro où les comédiens s'autoriseront
toutes les folies pour faire de votre
soirée un moment unique
donc nous on n'a pas l'extrait vidéo on
est là en vrai voilà moi je suis là
comme ça ouais moi je suis là ouais
comme ça voilà après les autres mais on
a failli mourir pour cette photo eh
ouais j'espère que vous l'appréciez on
était vraiment sur un toit dont la photo
est en pente et j'étais en talons les
risques du métier
d'ailleurs on en a perdu quatre
normalement n'est plus nombreux a du
coup on vient pour faire un extrait de
notre spectacle est en fait jeudi un
extrait mais en fait c'est très bizarre
parce qu'en fait c'est improvisé donc
oui ce sera forcément différent le 19
mars
mais on peut vous faire voilà un petit
come on pourrait dire sa petite
démonstrative démonstration de ce qu'on
peut faire
spectacle pour que après coignières sens
très bien complètement convaincu donc
farid où tu vas sortir est une variante
un accord ce qui va se passer
alors alors je sors at on ajouté
alors c'est un grand conférencier pas si
vous êtes au courant agroexpert d'
d'énormément de là les choses je suis un
expert
voilà oui bah sorte et ouais sort et tu
n'entends plus rien il est il est
conférencier et il adore animer des
conférences sur des sujets divers et
variés sauf que là le sujet c'est vous
quel est le définir d'accord donc je
vais vous demander un nom commun un peu
bizarre à walla qui est pas forcément
abordé en conférence
un jeudi 1 2 3 vous dit un mot d'accord
si je fais rire avec d'accord on arrête
là le spectacle on arrête la cpi et
merci beaucoup revint public ok 1 2 3
comment l'échiquier et yahia du level de
bain devant là parce que vous vous avez
dit quoi flamants roses
je prends de l'échiquier à genoux
demander maintenant un verbe s'il vous
plaît d'accord un verbe un peu compliqué
par exemple procrastiner paradoxalement
c'est un peuple qui est compliqué mais
c'est pas difficile à faire je compte
jusqu'à 3 un verbe 1 2 3
au fond la barre tergiverser un
spectacle interactif où on discute avec
les gens mais c'est vrai qu'avec les
masques c'est très curieux parce que
j'en trouve qu'entre eux et j'ai compris
tergiverser or moi je développe des
compétences complètement incroyable
attention donc j'ai l'échiquier
tergiverse et un adverbe s'il vous plaît
comme subtilement subrepticement
quelqu'un a des référents spectacle a
dit stationnement oui c'est un mot qui
finit en main mais de forme adverbiale
ok 1 2 3 difficilement
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup et
madame abaissé son masque pour me le
dire et je vous en remercie ceux du coup
j'ai tout compris
voilà a alors le thème de la conférence
et l'échiquier tergiverse difficilement
il va mener sa conférence mais il va
essayer de retrouver de quoi il parle
pendant qu'il mène sa conférence et
comment il va retrouver ce thème de
débat ce thème de conférence pardon
grâce à mes mime
je sens des rires qui sont proches de
l'humiliation mais sachez que je sais
tout me met d'accord ok je vois ça je
vois l'ambiance au caire mais au défi
il va retrouver donc les chics et
tergiversent difficilement il n'a rien
entendu
vous allez faire un maximum de bruit
pour qu'il vous entende et qu'il
revienne
et moi je vais lui faire deviner
attention fait un maximum de bruit c'est
l'heure de la conférence du grand show
tide allez-y faites du bruit musique
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir chers et n'ont
rien et rayonne et l'encouragent hrc
jean d'elancourt j'espère que vous allez
bien et merci de m'avoir invité
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de ce sujet
évidemment que je maîtrise parfaitement
puisqu'il s'agit des gens qui cousent
des choses voilà il faut évidemment
coudre alors pourquoi la couture c'est
important parce que des fois
eh ben on fait des petites claques la
voilà alors il faut absolument avoir une
table devant soi et ça c'est important
pour coudre on ne peut pas coudre sa
manche ni son short
si on n'a pas une petite table carrée
dedans soit pour coudre et la couture
c'est quelque chose c'est un art
magnifique où on fait des petits points
de couture comme ça et après on est
hyper content d'avoir réussi ce au point
de croix d'accord alors du coup qu'est
ce qui se passe
j'en veux vous dire la couture c'est
bien mais en même temps il faut
absolument faire des chèques il faut
faire des chèques pour acheter des
petites des petits chéquiers des petits
des petits des échecs des échecs des
échecs et bien des échecs et ben oui
alors le tap le plateau de l'échec
il faut le cas oui alors le plateau de
l'échec comme comment ça se fait ça ah
oui bah le chèque le plateau du chèque
voilà alors le plateau de l'échec et
qu'enfin on joue aux échecs car un
plateau vous êtes d'accord avec moi les
gens des locaux rue ou non bon mais
alors comment ça s'appelle cette merde
alors oui oui alors aller au bowling et
vous verrez qu'il y a des des espèces de
quille qui sont là oui eh ben oui ça
s'appelle des quilles qui sont là au
bowling ça n'a rien à voir strike voilà
alors chez quille et chez jacky lemée
chic l'échiquier peut-être l'échiquier
ok d'accord l'échiquier alors je suis
venu vous parler d'échiquier et non pas
de couture vous l'aurez vous même
remarquer alors évidemment l'échiquier
moi ça me rend perplexe
voilà ça prend même grognon 1 comme à
peu près tout le monde en ce moment
j'ai envie de faire oh là là c'est pas
bien l'échiquier mais en même temps et
il faut un gros mix heures un espèce de
gros mixeur pour pouvoir faire des
bronzes échec à l'énorme mxr un gros un
mois un rond alors que nous sommes sur
la planète terre et nous tournons autour
de la terre la planète terre terre voilà
vous ne ne soyons pas terre à terre
quelque part parce que l'échiquier n'est
pas terre à terre
l'échiquier d'école comme une fusée où
il est il est mort l'échiquier est mort
alors évidemment il en a ras la
casquette il est mort il est dans sa
tombe dans son tombeau dans son combo
dans son caveau dans son cercueil
cercueil non non la terre la terre et le
cercueil alors revenons au débat s'il
vous plaît alors j'ai envie de vous dire
à un moment donné j'essaye d'arroser
champagne pour tout le monde a vraiment
champagne on arrose ou pis on puisse sur
les gendarmes en a même c'est pas commis
de ça alors voilà alors des fois on
jette des cocktails molotov voilà on
jette des petits cocktails molotov des
cocktails des coques des coques mails
tels des côtes est alors évident et voit
alors oui alors des fois le jeton des
ptic des petites bouteilles oui alors d
co créé des de peace pis là la piste
l'habite parle de bits alors non nous ne
parlons pas de but évidemment car nous
sommes à il encourt lui ne sont pas là
pour parler de bits
alors évidemment j'ai envie du diable
rouge est on bien j'ai un jet walajeh
jeu je dois là je tu ils nous vous
filent alors absolument la terre terre
j'avoue stien j'étais les interjeté
c'est plus tergiverser ou tard j'ai
versé
je ne vois pas vous voyez une là
dedans mais enfin bon alors on en fera
après bien sûr mais alors donc nous
allons interjeter alors l'échiquier
interjette ok d'accord mais il
interjette quoi il est constipé
l'échiquier quelques pas et là on vit
mais il peut pas il se retient il est là
haut il va se lâcher bientôt qu'est ce
qu'il fait c'est hulk peut-être c'est
hulk le chimiquier est un peu comme hulk
qui interjette quoi alors gens là on va
par kudrin ça va me chercher là alors
qu'est ce qui se passe non on refait un
chèque on écrit on écrit quand on est un
chéquier on écrit on se gratte la tête
on réfléchit on pense et pense donc on
suit je pense donc je suis alors qu'est
ce qui se passe là-bas ya une caméra
pourquoi me contre la caméra parce qu'on
filme ce soit au film on est en direct à
la télé et on zappe
on zappe l'image la télé et la télé la
télé cinéma le grand écran mais quoi je
ne sais pas alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
nous sommes là et nous sommes en train
de le dire bon ok très bien
oui oui alors moi quand je vous parle je
vous parle actuellement je parle oui il
est beau il ya des mots il ya des sons
il ya d'écrit ya des ddd paroles des
paroles des paroles paroles paroles non
des mots des mots des phrases peut-être
il ya des phrases je ne sais pas ce qui
sort de ta bouche manchois ya dix ans
alors oui alors très bien très bien donc
du coup ce que j'ai envie de vous dire
des fois nous avons fait le premier pas
sur la lune un long retour mais alors
vraiment on avait mal aux pieds à que
vous avez des offres et des chaussures
orthopédiques il savait celles qui font
mal aux pieds trouve frein à hec le
canal ce soir voilà alors bon très bien
j'ai envie de dire tirons des spots sont
les choses janvier qu'est ce que c'est
alors qu'on a un petit sparadrap on tire
on tire très fort et la peau on
s'arrache avec les cheveux aussi les
cheveux aussi les perruques les cheveux
les cheveux les bleus il veut la
perruque je savais les poils les
poubelles c'est quoi ces des cheveux
alors oui les chocs je veux c'est la ga
agile de cheveux c'est au bout de la
langue d'un cheveu j'ai les dents la
dentition les dents les danseuses dont
cheveux l'étang cheveux l'étang
cheuvreux mesdames et messieurs alors
les dents oui ça fait jules elle est
hantée bien les dents huit dents dans il
aurait donc oui hier donc les dents
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont alors ils sautent
ils sont complètement alors nous rend
depuis tout est vraiment hors à main
mais vraiment mais alors quelque chose
et j'ai envie de dire on a un petit
bateau un petit cadeau et un petit
bateau de petites barques une petite
voix la caisse como alors on rame sur
quoi un canoë kayak par exemple ça peut
être un petit bateau laberge la berge
voilà c'est le petit port le petit
ponton sur lequel ont atterri vous
connaissez cette beauté non c'est pas
possible il est à terrière avec moi à
des regards cette phase est un petit
pourtant voilà mesdames et messieurs je
vais vous parler de quelque chose
d'incroyable des fois on est content de
marché 1 et on est là sur sûre et un
truc rond voilà qui fait des vagues
voilà qu'est ce que c'est grâce à un
bocal peut-être on est dans un bocal
non on n'est pas dans un box you n'est
pas très clair un pour l'instant mais je
cherche un peu mais bon dans cette
conférence oui il y en a 10 ont tous
disent oui disent ouais disent oui ma 10
10 10 dans 10 alors bas ont recours
maintenant alors on court beaucoup et
voilà le fil alors qu'en vingt deux fils
voilà on a dix coups de fil par jour
mesdames et messieurs il faut le savoir
le fil disent 'voilà fils 10 c'est un
mot que tu meures et où c&a alors fil à
leurs fils ou nous sommes fil dentaire
mesdames fil des ans j'allais fils 10 la
suite n'a pas lundi ce qu'il dit ce fils
nous sommes dyslexiques peut-être non
nissen difficilement difficilement quoi
c'est ça qu'elles gagnent un grillon
j'ai effacé alors un jeu les jeux du
bateau moi alors je vais résumer on va
arriver à micron bientôt mais
difficilement ce à quoi j'ai fait une
bulle te fous de moi difficilement les
dents mais quel rapport avec des vrais
leaders rapide bon écoutez monsieur on
va en parler en coulisses on va
retravailler nos minimes en tout cas
l'échiquier tergiverse difficilement et
puisque tout voilà ciboure voilà merci
bonsoir
tu m'as fait une bordel c'est vers
un schéma c'était une tâche merci
merci julie et paris dont les retrouvera
j'espère un peu plus près le 19 mars
c'est fini pour le chapitre de l'humour
on parle un petit peu de jeunes publics
maintenant donc un registre un peu
différent
accroche toi si tu peux le mercredi 31
mars un spectacle pour les enfants à
partir de 5 ans qui mélange adroitement
danse et jonglage
les deux artistes conversant jonglant
justement alors il y aura du mime aussi
d'ailleurs
et ils sont à quatre bras 4 jean et sans
parole ils se soutiennent sa compagne se
perdent tombe d'école sans jamais perdre
de vue la fameuse petite balle blanche
on proposera un atelier parents enfants
avant le spectacle voilà ce que ça fait
partie des choses dans le cadre de la
très jeune public qu'on a à coeur de
proposer c'est à dire des moments en
amont ou en aval du spectacle où les
parents les grands parents peuvent
explorer un petit peu plus loin ce
qu'ils auront vu en discuter échanger
voilà un spectacle pour les plus petits
maintenant petits monstres
le samedi 13 février à découvrir dès 3
ans c'est une adaptation du livre papa
de philippe corentin publié à l'école
des loisirs
ce spectacle qui mêle comédiens
marionnettes chansons contes avec
délicatesse le tumultueux mais
fantastique chemin de la découverte et
de l'action l'acceptation de la
différence
et puis un autre spectacle monsieur
blanchette et le loup samedi 22 mai un
spectacle qui j'espère pourra se jouer
hors les murs dans la prairie de la
ferme du mousseau si la météo le permet
s'agit d'un texte de josé pliya qui
s'inspire autant de la chèvre de
monsieur seguin que du soleil des
indépendances damas douze kourouma alors
dans nos cieux blanchette et le loup
monsieur est un éleveur prospère de
belles chèvre aux pelages variés
monsieur n'a qu'un seul objectif dans la
vie vivre heureux avec ses chèvres mais
monsieur un problème son voisin le loup
voyous vagabond ne cherche quant à lui
qu'à séduire les chèvres de monsieur
alors deux histoires cruelles comme
beaucoup de comptes qui résume chacune
inscrits dans sa propre tradition le
tragique de l'existence et qui sont pour
les enfants l'occasion à travers un
récit à suspense de s'interroger autour
de notions telles que les conséquences
du mensonge les conditions des libertés
ou le pouvoir de ceux qui veulent notre
bien et un dernier spectacle jeune
public et qui sera aussi le dernier
spectacle que je vous présenterai ce
soir
un pinocchio samedi 30 janvier c'est la
dernière création de la compagnie des
dramaticules que nous accueillerons dans
le cadre d'une résidence que nous avons
mené avec eux depuis trois ans vous avez
peut-être vu la menace qu'ils ont créés
il ya deux saisons
alors ce pinocchio qui sera un spectacle
pour petits et grands à partir de 8 ans
s'inspirent de l'adaptation du roman
italien du 19e siècle écrit par carlo
collodi les aventures de pinocchio et
pour donner vie à cette vie cette
fantaisie adressées voilà vraiment un
spectacle un public familial
les dramaticules invente à l'instar de
fellini du studio numéro 5 de la
cinecittà une fabrique théâtrale placée
sous le signe des arts forains lieu de
tous les possibles
alors jérémie le louët metteur en scène
et comédien des dramaticules est en
répétition ce soir c'est la générale du
spectacle puisque la première a lieu
demain il ne pouvait pas être là mais il
nous a adressée également à un petit mot
bonsoir à tous mais j'espère que vous
allez bien ils encourent je pouvais pas
être avec vous ce soir parce que je crée
pinocchio demain et comme toujours avec
une première on a encore plein de choses
à faire
donc vous êtes en avant première
sur le plateau et comme vous le voyez
c'est assez coloré le travail sur la
scénographie sur des costumes aussi sur
les lumières a été très important ce que
je voulais que ce soit une féerie pour
pour grands et petits
j'ai lu ce roman qui est un des plus
grands classiques de la littérature
italienne adultes je ne vais pas du tout
découvert enfant je connaissais
l'adaptation de disney comme la plupart
d'entre vous mais je connaissais pas le
roman a poussé adultes que j'ai été
fasciné par par cette oeuvre à la fois
très sont très sombres et et qui met en
lumière aussi ce qu'il y a de 2,2
mélancolique à devenir un adulte et qui
essaye de parler de ce que l'on perd
quand on devient adulte
pour ceux qui connaissent le travail de
la compagnie sont les mêmes acteurs que
que lors des spectacles précédents
puisqu'il nous sommes une troupe
nous sommes six comédiens en plateau et
de techniciens et et j'espère que que ce
spectacle qui est une célébration de la
théâtralité vous enchantera je vous dis
à très vite et je vous embrasse
bonne soirée à vous avez un aperçu du
décor derrière qui est merveilleux et
c'est vraiment la particularité
dramaticules peut vous attend un vrai
feu d'artifice de décors d'accessoires
quand il dit une explosion de la
théâtralité c'est c'est vraiment ça
m'ouvre on dérape de ben voilà de les
accompagner sur cette création elle aura
peut-être d'autres mais en tout cas là
on a été particulièrement proche de dans
tout ce processus de création là on a
balayé ensemble l'essentiel des
spectacles qui composent la saison mais
il me reste à vous parler d'autres
rendez vous qui vous attendent la
reprise des api your à partir de janvier
alors pas au même rythme qu auparavant
on sera plus sur un jeudi sur deux avec
un appui your et une jam session
toujours sous la houlette de vincent
touchard il y aura également une release
party de l'album que vincent a réalisé
la saison dernière avec ses nombreux
acolytes que vous avez déjà croisé de
nombreuses fois que ce soit au piano au
piano bas ou dans le cadre des apps your
et donc on organisera avec lui ben voilà
une petite soirée pour 7,7 célébrer
cette sortie d'album au prisme et des
vacances créatives aussi qu'ils vont
reprendre elles reprennent dès la
toussaint les vacances créatives dure
entre trois et quatre jours sur les
petites vacances scolaires et sont
toujours accrochés un des spectacles de
la saison est animé par un des comédiens
artistes du spectacle donc à la
toussaint on commencera avec du théâtre
est en lien avec le spectacle pinocchio
pour les adolescents à partir les jeunes
adolescents à partir de 11 ans sur les
vacances d'hiver ce sera encore du
théâtre en lien avec le cercle des
illusionnistes pour les jeunes à partir
de 11 ans et puis en vacances de pâques
accroche toi si tu peux le spectacle de
jonglage donc je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure
donnera lieu
à des vacances créatives formé mouvement
qui mélange arts plastiques et danse et
qui seront pilotés par un chorégraphe
gilles verièpe avec qui est aussi mon
collabore depuis de nombreuses années
nous avons pris un très grand plaisir à
construire cette saison pour vous je
suis convaincu que vous y trouverez de
quoi faire pétiller vos yeux ou vos
méninges animer vos zygomatiques venir
au théâtre c'est nous permettre ensemble
de marquer une pause dans notre
quotidien pour envisager le monde sous
un autre angle
prendre le temps de ce fameux pas de
côté 1 pour envisager la vie
différemment
je voudrais finir surtout par saluer
tout le travail de l'équipe de la
direction des dynamiques culturelles
l'équipe du prise une équipe des
enseignements artistiques qui réalise un
travail au quotidien
absolument fabuleux remercie aussi
l'équipe de tv 78 qui est là ce soir
vous les avez pas vu mais en fait la
soirée a été filmée elle sera
retransmise vendredi soir sur télé 78
vous pourrez si vous le voulez la
regarder de nouveau remercié toute
l'équipe de la technique des
intermittents du spectacle qui nous
permette voilà de vous proposer tout ce
que tout ce dont je viens de vous parler
parce que c'est on est vraiment sur un
travail collégial avec des choses qui se
voit sont les spectacles les artistes
qui a pressé vous l'avez déjà devient un
très gros travail de fourmi il nous
tarde de pouvoir vous retrouver et pour
débattre sur la jeu c'est moi qui vous
ai parlé beaucoup mais ce qu'on aime
aussi c'est vraiment à voir vos retours
positifs ou négatifs après après les
spectacles leur petite entorse à la
tradition ce soir on ne peut pas vous
proposer de verre de l'amitié comme
c'est l'habitude qu'ovide oblige mais on
vous propose de nous retrouver quand
même dans le hall du théâtre pour
échanger la billetterie est ouverte si
vous avez fait votre choix
on sera ravi de pouvoir échanger avec
vous longue vie au théâtre et au
spectacle vivant et à très vite
vous pouvez applaudir virginie mens s'il
vous plaît j'ai dit très fort bravo de
et a été parfait travaux tout de théâtre
tout est écrit pour moi j'étais en
coulisses j'ai adoré tout ce que tu as
dit ça c'est génial a souffert sur 4
donne à tous les spectacles de la saison
non mais il ya un truc état paye mais à
un moment donné elle a parlé de son coup
de coeur de la saison il s'était pas
nous mais ça à part ça le reste c'est
très bien voilà on va se remettre
ouais bah du coup on avant que de se
retrouver peut-être là bas pour discuter
pour ceux qui veulent discuter prendre
réserver des places avant de vous
laisser partir on voulait terminer un
peu en vous remerciant déjà être
complètement de la lumière dans la salle
et on voulait régler les petits
problèmes du quotidien voilà on veut
voulait on veut que vous partiez là car
je voyais les peureux
on est on est potes on est cool
maintenant donc je vais vous demander à
trois on va expulser des petits
problèmes du quotidien un truc qui nous
embêtent de tous les jours a par exemple
moi je transpire beaucoup à oyonnax ain
vous le voyez madame o sa réaction de la
dame a fait oui oui j'ai pas vu mais
derrière le masque je voyais bien
je sais que c'est un problème depuis
tout le temps voilà donc par exemple un
voisin qui crie trop fort un petit
problème du quotidien palapa la faim
dans le monde vraiment un truc qui vous
concerne vous à trois on s'en débarrasse
comme ça on parle et j'ai d'accord
attention à troyes 1 2 3 et noir jais
d'accord des noirs la baignoire mais les
gens qui se lavent c'est un vrai bon
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient bien
reprennent avec la baignoire à un souci
de baignoire vous avez un souci de
baignoire c'est à dire il ya quelqu'un
qu'elle avait son aquarium dans votre
baignoire 1 et qui a fait un trou d'eau
dans ça n'a pas été souvent des gens qui
viennent avec des aquariums je suis sûr
que tu t'exposes pour à la part pour
l'acsa baignoire elle avait un problème
les gens qui a fait rentrer chez elle
mais oui il a raison mais c'est
quelqu'un avec qui vous visiez 1 à ccc
chez donc c'est pas de ta baignoire
d'accord c'est vrai que tu as volé son
appart date à récupérer c'est très
compliqué et aviez alors on va essayer
de comprendre tu t'appelles comment va
ton problème
on va parler c'est ma façon avec son
problème on est d'accord on va l'aider
maeva ton problème si j'ai bien compris
c'est que quelqu'un a pété ta baignoire
en avant un aquarium dedans d'accord
d'accord ok c'est la première fois qu'on
nous dise a vraiment essayé de nager
c'est tellement haut le réveil du lanl
assez d'accord sa baignoire a été péter
par un aquarium julie est ce qu'on
retrouve à résoudre ça eh ben on va le
faire est ce que vous voulez le faire
avec nous alors on va avoir besoin de
vous vraiment maeva et tu fais quoi dans
la vie juste maeva il ferme tu te remets
tes la zone et qui fait tellement chez
look wayne on s'est bien posé cette
question d'accord et autres à mettre
dans une ferme pédagogique armes
pédagogique est justement donc en avant
un aquarium forcément la baignoire cpt
maeva offre à régler ton problème on va
tous le faire ensemble
par contre on aimerait comme si avant de
partir vous pouvez y aller on va mettre
une ambiance de fou furieux
une ambiance de dingue dans la salle ok
on veut vous entendre très très fort
est-ce que vous êtes prêts ok vasile ans
le truc mon silence le registre ici et
dans cet entretien ok tu peux pas vous
avez des problèmes
benoît les gens viennent nettoyer leur
apport yable c'est tout et c'est pas
votre appartement mais ça va devenir
très fière
car sa mémoire et tout et tout le monde
ment et quand on est énervé car en été
et qassam des lois et traités maeva et
énervé car ce sont des noirs et tout
était mal de travail dans gmail
terminologique ouais t'as qui n'est pas
très logique
j'ai une solution aux femmes maintenant
plein soit dans l'aquarium à port louis
bapes été battu
ouais maeva ce qui est logique du
travail pédagogique à l indice des gens
chez elle mais à mes amis que l sa
baignoire et tout était alors marié à l
égard des arts est invité des gens
louches et maintenant bret a qu'à
prendre des douches
ah ouais du coup
j'ai dit ouais super mais je n'ai juste
rajouter la cimade giga évasive
l'échiquier les fossiles table écrit la
prison sera sensible à la réussite
un feu d'artifice berisha première est
bien difficile à avaler quoi se gèle
tous elle est toute énervée la douche le
coup en l'air toujours le poing en l'air
le corps est en fait bien sourire de
polaires et paribas les énergies cassard
est mort et tous traités ni maurepas
et il est encore jeune
fait car sa baignoire et tout était
marivin et énervé car sa baignoire
et ouais ok merci c'était pour vous le
don chautagne avec julie c'est tellement
je t'aime avec farid c'est le grand show
tech avec cette fille qui travaille dans
une ferme pédagogique
ouais si vous avez 10 avec mariama laver
mais il va vous êtes france la fin voilà
vous invite chez aig ont fait un échange
dans le hall aquarium pas aquarium
on va se créer du lien merci beaucoup
belle soirée
[Applaudissements]